c'est bien lundi c'est le premier jour
de la semaine on est heureux de
retrouver ses habits comme à l'école ça
y est on y est les Grandes Gueules
débarquent dans la plus grande ferme du
monde en direct du stand des Hauts de
France et le pavillon 3 du Salon de
l'Agriculture là où se trouve toutes les
régions les Grandes Gueules seront
quasiment toute la semaine en direct de
cette grande ferme avec nos GG qui vont
venir partager alors en même temps on a
les annonces oui on est vraiment en
direct voici ce qu'Elisabeth borne c'est
envoyé dans le gosier dans l'ordre
chronologique en moins d'une heure elle
a débuté sa journée à 10h du matin au
stand outre-mer
le riz chauffé
[Musique]
voilà puis une petite bière
on l'a fini quand même
oui parce qu'il y avait du rhum avant
une petite huître pour faire passer tout
ça suivi d'une patte de fruits
et
la première ministre a adoré
du cerf toute la journée
une vraie reine qu'elle prestance
vous savez très bien qu'il allait faire
fureur en même temps vu le prix
ma chérie
je vous remercie ça a été un plaisir et
vous êtes nouvelle en vrai
mais sinon c'était formidable autant
quand vous disiez du bien des aides
covid c'était super mais la réflexion à
la fin c'était un peu beauf un peu
lourdingue monsieur
toute la pelouse
[Musique]
est-ce que vous auriez un message pour
Cyril bah je l'ai vu il y a 48 heures
même pas oui c'est vrai tu as passé un
bout de la Saint-Valentin ensemble
qu'est-ce que vous avez fait vous en
plus vous lui poser la question
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
Gilles Bouleau et Laurent Ruquier
d'accord melizabeth borne était
accompagnée de Marc féno le ministre de
l'Agriculture qui lui n'était pas contre
l'idée de se jeter un petit calva
derrière la cravate aujourd'hui
national c'est une mieux en mieux
d'ailleurs on se demande pourquoi on
peut avoir de la de l'alcool à la
buvette de l'Assemblée vous avez aussi
une bouteille de rouge
27 oui non mais les gens qui nous
regardent dans les entreprises il y a
pas d'alcool que je sache ah c'est news
il y a pas une buvette
donc moi je m'interroge même sur le fond
d'avoir une buvette à l'Assemblée ils
ont que ça à faire tu les mets à l'Évian
demain matin mais notre journaliste
préféré de ce premier week-end de salon
de l'agriculture c'est lui qui est allé
en touriste au salon il avait laissé les
fiches à la maison le Duplex était pas
fou qu'est-ce qu'on s'est marré au stand
du typhonche
vous êtes chef cuisinier chef étoilé de
pas chef étoilé
à Strasbourg
à Mont-de-Marsan mais merci de votre
venue là pour l'émission
je suis pas purite quand tu travailles
tu picole pas pardonne-moi moi je veux
bien qu'on se mettait on va se mettre
ici
il roule par terre excusez-moi il
vomissent
le journal
certains députés commanderaient des
coupettes dès 11h du matin donc d'autres
sont au rhum à partir de 16h un député
ce serait fait ramasser par les serveurs
de la buvette tellement il était mal
dans la buvette et dans les jardins
c'était alcool à gogo jusqu'à 3h du
matin ce fameux député qui aurait vomi
après avoir consommé trop d'alcool
serait un insoumis l'intéressé d'aimant
anonymement dans les colonnes du JDD la
Tour Eiffel en poireaux et en carotte
c'est une très très bonne idée de ces
centrales 3 c'est joli et 4 un jeu de
mots Tour Eiffel Tour Eiffel comme
fruits et légumes McDonald's à partir du
7 mars va remplacer à ses potatoes par
des frites de légumes et ça va durer
trois ou quatre semaines ça va dépendre
en fait c'est une opération de test pour
voir comment les clients vont apprécier
voici à quoi voilà voici à quoi
ressembleront les frites de légumes il y
a trois types de légumes il y a trois
types de légumes des betteraves rouges
des carottes et du panais pour
l'opération McDo va déployer 3000 tonnes
de légumes soit l'équivalent de 12 EHPAD
pour rappel c'est la reprise
pour rappel pour rappel Yann
je l'ai perdu sur celle-ci je vois je
vois je vois les fans de potéitos faire
une crise de panique
provisoire bon coup le temps d'une
opération spéciale un test de 3-4
semaines pour déterminer si les clients
adhèrent au concept de l'accompagnement
plus vedgie et question prix pas de
surcoût pour le client une nouvelle
étape dans la longue épopée de McDo pour
convaincre que non ça marque n'est pas
que synonyme de malbouffe non mais quand
je vais au McDo c'est pas pour manger du
légumes
j'y vais pour voilà manger gras pour
manger gras pour manger ça
je suis désolé et en plus des frites non
mais des frites de légumes attends tu
veux mon sa plonge dans l'huile je suis
désolé faut arrêter c'est de s'énerver
de la pomme de terre des frites c'est
des frites je suis désolé
[Applaudissements]
selon une étude les femmes dormiraient
mieux avec leur chien qu'avec leur
conjoint vrai ou faux et c'est vrai que
c'est très apaisant de dormir avec son
chien c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que tous
les soirs Vincent Bolloré s'endort avec
Pascal Praud